hello my name is Margaret Fong I'm a
senior scientist at Ministry technology
today I'll be talking to you about
technical features of the qiyamah clips
are any asset with the sequencing
readouts that my team has developed
first click outlined up my socks in
first half I'll provide a brief review
of Geo mix technology and I'd like to
point out three features in particular
in the second half I'll review of NGS
Rita and discuss on technical data
the Geo mixed as DSD is a novel I we
multiply exactly that digitally
characterized with RNA and perfect
expression from spatially discreet
regions of interest within tissue
sections here's a high-level overview of
our workflow on the Left it starts with
our high Flex mixtures of impeaching
probes for RNA or antibodies for protein
the probe head is the analyte specific
region and the probe tail is the
detection region
between the head and tail is the UVB
photo cleavable spacer
after processing the slides and loading
RDSP instruments in the middle here 20x
scans are generated to image the tissue
sections far wise are selected and
ultraviolet light illuminated to photo
release the detection field of the
probes
herbs are collected and quantitated
either by direct hybridization with mana
stream and counter technology or in what
I'll be covering today by sequencing
using the Illumina platforms the result
is a rich data set of expression
profiling region by region
so the first feature i'd like to
highlight is gilman multi analyte
capabilities to do this two serial
sections are processed the RNA layer
will undergo in situ hybridisation
protocol while the protein layer
undergoes and immunohistochemistry
protocol
the Phoenix instrument will image new
serial sections and the user can go
register images let's overlapping ROI
this results in high flex multiple
analytes RNA plus protein and analysis
of the tissue sample
the second feature family para is at the
heart of our geo mix technology this
ability to shape ultraviolet light onto
the tissues essentially it's my
protection by light this is done with a
digital mirror device that contains a
million years of about 1 micron width
and height such that 100 mirrors are
used to eliminate one small T cell shown
here in the middle is an elimination
pattern based on the morphology of the
tissue the tumor region is stained with
the visualization marker and cytokeratin
to the colored and gold here and a tumor
mass is created to profile the tumor
region only
and then the inverse of this mask is
created to profile the microenvironment
this leads to five unique ROI profiling
modalities an expansive set of
user-defined tools depending on
application and experimental design this
includes geometric profiling resonance
profiling contouring from a fixed
distance a gridded pattern for unbiased
assessment of your tissues and rare rare
self profiling for example selecting all
the tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
the last feature at Michael highlight is
specific to detection and quantification
of the photo release Allah goes by ng s
readout and what my team is abilities
local pros targeting the same transcript
our molecular bar-coded
and quantitative such that there are
updated plan independent counts for
transcripts this leads to very robust
connotation where during the analysis
there were at what approach and then
target that roughly due to absence or
off target effects they are when we
identify and may be filtered out
Harvick chapter average which minimizes
inherent Prout Pacific effects such as
sequence compositions and hybridization
efficiencies
additionally because multiple approach
would ban the transcript this also has
potential sex life variants which I'll
click on in the next sections to
the sleeps in my foot pack on my clock
key omits DSP highlights are any acting
with NGS read up
we developed the high flex RNA channel
that targets key pathways in the tumor
microenvironment and immune response
typically we combine the content from
three of our best-selling can character
and Chandra apps a half-wave immune
profiling and IO 360
within this channel we have negative 52
probes that measure non specific
findings
which defines our level of detection and
the robust housekeeper panel of 12 teams
to normalize for differences in cell
number within different sizes and shapes
of regions of interest
the table shows a number of concept
panels we developed leading up to our
commercial set of 1600 more than 1600
target
here's overview of the NGS workflow
starting with the library press
the sequencing and then the data
prophecy
let's beyond like to note is that I
won't cover today is that we have
enabled our sequencing workflow for
protein also and the library prep is
shown on the left here
for the high flex RNAs a we have library
press involved PCR and amplification
with investing using unique dual indices
which I'll cover in design and seven
slides after library prep our weifare
multiplex on Illumina instrument and the
read depth depends on experimental
conditions tissue type sample qualities
are life size and number of hours
multiplied but in general typical
sequence being read depth could fit for
example 96 our lives with a standard
workflow on an X each
or on instruments demultiplex see what
the Linda unique dual index workflows we
we process the data through our
bioinformatics pipeline which is pretty
straightforward involved
trimming the sequences align them
releasing removing PCR duplicates with
our unique molecular identifiers emi and
creating a digital count
like to highlight some design features
of our 5 flex RNA acetate in particular
on the right side you'll see the photo
release oligo that comes off of the
tissue that will be sequence there's a
um line vetted in there and that is
designed to be at adjacent to read 1
which ensures a high complexity during
the image analysis and base calling
algorithms during these sequencing
the barcode is a 12-week with high bar
code identifies the analyte and those
codes have been optimized we optimize
to prevent barcode collisions with at
least three mismatches between different
barcodes
the oh my itself is a 14-yard which is a
large molecular state to accommodate
many different types of experimental
design and prevents underestimation of
molecule can't
and lastly as I mentioned there are
unique dual indices and those are I
automatically created to have a Hamming
distance of two between the two between
different indices and our color balance
on the two color and four color
platforms and all these design features
of our Illumina infection tag create a
high quality sequencing either on Cheney
platforms of aluminum
next I'd like to go through some of the
technical performance data
that we had on some of our development
panels
on the left you can see the
reproducibility of serial sections these
sections were 5 micron SPD sections of
23 different settle lines
and there are 14 to 12 G targets here
making up 5,000 yards pros
I'm introducing bilities in the mill
you'll see that one thing that we see
often is the scalability of the multi
taxis and what what is shown here is
experiments on the x-axis where they see
a 9/16 panel comprised of 928 different
probes and comparing that overlapping
number of probes into a higher left the
14:12 gene panel which is about 5000
probes they can see is a nice
correlation of counts between the two
and what that suggests is that the
protostar
acting independently of each other
regardless of the cleft side
must be on the right is concordance with
an orthogonal method so on the x-axis is
the same channel 96 gene panel using our
encounter direct hybridization readout
and preparing counts from that to our
NGS readout of that phase 90 16 panel
what you see is a nice correlation which
validates the cap would also suggest
that the library present itself is not
skewing the cap
here are some more technical data and
what I'd like to go through is some of
the raw data comes off of of these
experiments and so on the left is our
control sspe section with 23 different
cell lines that are spotted in this
array
and we use these control cell lines as
invalidation it has a number of
orthogonal data types such as the end
chatter assay or RNA seek sequencing so
we validate our count or NGS counts with
that
we also use these to validate our probes
which show are four of the graphs
writing a draft from this experiment
first graph on the upper left is the
negative control so it's the glass
surface just drawing an ROI on the glass
surface the other three are tissues and
what you'll see is sort of in this 90 16
panel are that the approach sort of
grouped together and jump up above
background and the background is defined
by some ER cc- probes that are just
scrambled sequences highlighted in
yellow on the right side of each graft
and you can see that there is a sort of
a baseline of negative not specific find
use that we define as our levels of
detection
so I'd like to show this graph to people
just to show you can see the backgrounds
and engage that with the ERC see and
then you see the signal which are the
ten probes that just above that
background and that's pretty much the
raw data and how that looks
in the next slide it's the same
experiment but draft in a different way
to show the ten different tiles for each
sample and so on the top row of graphs
you'll see each color represents the
twenty three cell lines of that control
experiments and across
you'll see the ten different probes is
you can see that they all sort of
hovering around and seeing counts for
most of it the left two are tumor
specific markers and you can see some
specificity where the XP cancer samples
epithelial samples are high most the
next four are sort of immune markers and
diffuse from cell lines that are derived
from immune cell types adjuster cats are
high in these different markers d3 UTP
our sheet for samples
one thing to notice is that because of
this tiling of these tens probes and is
shown on the bottom is that it does lead
to the potential of detective splice
variants and we're just showing two
examples here from experiment p10 and C
27 but on the left and the pecans is D
that is the cell lines you see are s the
ten probes that map two exons for have a
low count can start to its neighbors
and lastly I wanted to go through some
of the validation with the ihd
visualization markers
so on the left there's tons of tissue
that is gained with DNA the cd3 a t-cell
marker and PM ck
consume among different morphologies of
this possible tissue the green
highlights the epithelial cells and
the pink highlights the t-cells
in this experiment we gritted the our
lives of 300 microns and tighten length
and we've shown sort of this expression
profile of the keratins
within our within our panel
that matches sort of the morphology of
the tissue as well as the CD breeze
expressions and so this been nice the
spatial and molecular fingerprints of
the tonsil
so some concluding thoughts that we've
demonstrated with the development panels
that which is a 52 RNA expression
profiling and FSP tissues with 5000 in
situ hybridization approach that
represent about 1,500 teams involved in
amino oncology pathways
at GFC and ef3 dot was determined to be
after it nor bus based on the
reproducibility cross-platform
components and validation of the digital
counts
the scalability and high throughput of
NGS readout the most accessibility of T
omics ESP experimental designs this
includes sampling a few regions furnish
you or possibly unbiased coverage across
tissues such as the grid
lastly I highlighted the feature of geo
mcc's DSD with and just read out
measures the mRNA abundance with up to
ten independent probe title on the
transcript and enables the ability for
in-situ depression of experience
so with that I'll hand it over to Maya
so we'll be talking about a project that
we've been collaborating
what are fun
Thank You Margaret
so we will move on to our next
presentation
my name is Maya kuru I'm an assistant
professor of dermatology and pathology
at University of California Davis and
our project that I will be talking about
today is identification of cell type
specific RNA biomarker candidates in
Milan acidic tumors using the digital
spacial profiling that Margaret talked
about so firstly I would like to
acknowledge everyone that took part in
this so from UC Davis dr. John
Macpherson and scientists at nano
strength
Margaret Michelle Kriner and Joseph
Smeaton and myself I have no financial
conflicts of interest
so the hypothesis for this study is that
the key genes that are involved in
melanoma Genesis serve as objective
biomarker candidates and potential
therapeutic targets that would
ultimately lead to decrease morbidity
and mortality from melanoma to give you
some background about melanoma so it is
the most dangerous type of the common
forms of skin cancer and early diagnosis
is critical to improving outcomes the
diagram I am showing here shows survival
rate over time stratified based on the
primary tumor stage and primary tumor
stage of melanoma is determined mainly
by the thickness of the tumor so if we
look at this graph the p1 a and t1 B
stage tumors those are tumors that are
only under one millimeter in thickness
and the survival rates are very good
usually around 90 or over 90% however
when we go down to the T for B tumors
these are tumors that are over four
millimeters in thickness and all
serrated the survival rates drop down
under 50% so it's critical to diagnose
melanoma early however sometimes an
accurate diagnosis is challenging and
the main reason is that benign malan
acidic tumors called me by or moles can
act as mimics of melanoma and this can
result in diagnostic disagreement
between pathologists who usually make
the diagnosis of melanoma in up to 10 to
25 percent of cases which is quite high
therefore there are an increasing
interest in the last few years to
develop molecular tests to improve the
diagnostic accuracy of Milan acidic
tumors as well as tests to more
accurately define prognosis of these
patients and also for advanced melanomas
to determine who are the best candidates
for certain therapies like targeted or
immunotherapy so if we look at the
diagnostic tests that are currently
available
these include comparative genomic
reputation and fluorescence in situ
hybridization additionally there is a
newer test that is available that looks
at gene expression of melanoma tumors
and another test that is worth
mentioning is a prognostic test that
also looks at gene expression of
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tumors
the problem however with this test is
that they may not be technically
adequate for tumors that are in the
indeterminate stage that are
characterized by low cellularity and low
purity that would post challenges to the
technology these currently available
tests are using therefore we wanted to
look at spatially result analysis that
might enable identification of novel
biomarker candidates that could then
potentially be used for for diagnostic
and prognostic purposes so the slide
here I'm showing shows a melanoma up at
the top is the epidermis which is the
top layer of the skin and down below is
the second layer the skin which is
called the dermis and the circles here
are showing regions of interest and the
heterogeneity within this tumor if we
start from the top the top circle shows
melanoma in situ so that is melanoma
that's growing within the epidermis but
it's not invasive then if we go all the
way down to the bottom on the right side
that circle shows invasive melanoma and
these melanocytes are malignant invading
into the dermis on the left side in the
middle of the slide roughly is another
region of interest that shows
inflammatory cell infiltrates that are
very typical in especially in malignant
melanoma DIC tumors
and then on the lower left side is
another region of interest that shows
melanocytes that look different from the
invasive melanoma cells these
melanocytes are smaller and may
represent a precursor nevis associated
with this tumor
so in this study we wanted to use an RNA
assay with next-generation sequencing
readout on formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue steer I've some
patients and this is the Geo MX digital
spacial profile or profiler that
Margaret talked about and I will just
very briefly go over the steps but I
want to highlight the main thing here
which is that we can use formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue and and that is
one of the key things of this experiment
so firstly we take a decision section
and hybridize that with the probes that
we're using and then we image the slide
and select the regions of interest and
we will go over that in the next slides
and then as Margaret described we will
use UV cleavage to cleave off the ala
goals of the probes and then aspirate
these into a micro capillary and
dispense them onto a 96-well plate and
this has been followed by
next-generation sequencing to establish
counts for these probes and Margaret
went into more details of the process
but basically the first step is the NGS
library prep and there are the unique
identifiers one of the that identifies
the probe and another unique molecular
identifier that enables digital counting
of the reads and then we this is
followed by sequencing bioinformatics
and statistical analysis to then
establish gene counts
so in the first phase of our study we
wanted to evaluate the technical
performance and reproducibility of this
technology in Milan acidic tumors and we
used four tumor types that span the
spectrum of Milan acidic tumors from
benign to malignant and these included
common nevis dysplastic nevus melanoma
in situ and melanoma we had one case for
each tumor type the pilot RNA panel
included over a thousand probes for over
100 genes and we used digital spatial
profiler replicates so these are serial
sections of the same tumor tissue with
the RO is aligned and we also use
sequencing replicates which are
duplicate PCR and sequencing from the
same DSP tag collection so firstly I
will show you the selection of ro eyes
so the HD image up at the top shows one
of the tumors that we analyzed and the
circles depicted there are the RO is we
selected so for example ro I 17 shown on
the lower left side has a region that is
enriched for immune cells and the
immunofluorescence image on the right
side shows red fluorescence which is for
CD 3 which is the PSL marker for roi 13
on the right side we have a region of
interest that shows melanoma cells
within the superficial dermis and on the
immunofluorescent image on the right
side this shows green fluorescence and
where we used to Milan acidic markers
we classified the ROI types based on the
cell types we classified them into
immune read into Milan aside rich into
terra genocide and Milan aside rich
areas and these typically were areas
that included epidermis where the Milan
acidic tumor was growing and we also had
areas that were mixed that that included
melanocytes immune cells and sometimes
keratinocytes and lastly we had regions
that included control epidermis only so
firstly I want to show you the sequence
steps across these different roi so we
had a total of 25 million reads and on
the x-axis are all the different roi and
on the y-axis are the read counts so
firstly the two stars that you see there
are the negative controls so we expect
few reads there as is shown on the
diagram secondly there are black boxes
on some of the RO eyes and these were
areas that were under sequence examples
and these were excluded and in in total
sequencing was successful for at least
one of the PCR replicates for most of
the RO is so 95 out of 96 are aligned
secondly I want to show you how well the
digital spatial profiler replicates and
the PCR replicates correlated so the top
diagram there shows the DSB duplicate so
these were the serial tissue sections
that were analyzed showing very
reproducible results and then the lower
diagram shows the PCR duplicates again
correlating very well next I want to
show you how the mallanna site
associated gene counts correlate with
the immunofluorescence staining with
mallanna side markers so here on the
left side are the RO is we analyzed from
one tumor and the ones that are
highlighted with the green outline are
the ones that are showing melano sites
within the ROI as shown with the green
fluorescence and then if we look on the
right side we see the gene counts and we
see higher peak higher gene counts for
those ROI so for example if we take ROI
13 which has green fluorescence and is a
mallanna side rich area and look at the
peak on the right side and we see
hygiene counts there formal and static
markers and then we compare it to ROI 17
which is an ROI that is immune rich and
look at the gene counts on the right
side we see that the G counts are low
for that ROI as it is an immune rich
area
on the next slide we're doing the same
thing but for immune gene counts now so
the RO eyes that have immune rich areas
are highlighted with the red outline
boxes and then again on the right side
is the diagram showing gene counts if we
look at the same ROI so ROI 17 which is
an immune rich area and we look at the
gene counts on the right we see that
they're hiding counts for immune cells
and then if we look at ROI 13 which was
a Milan aside which area and look at the
gene counts on the right side we see
that the gene counts are low for the
mulana side rich roi
so the first phase established the
technical reproducibility of the
technology and then in the next phase we
wanted to look at gene expression across
tumor types and across cell types to
identify novel biomarkers and we used
the same four tumor types common neva
dysplastic nevi melanoma in situ and
melanoma and in this experiment we had
three cases per tumor type with a total
of 12 tumors and we used an expanded RNA
panel that included roughly 5000 probes
for over 1400 genes
this table shows the sample
characteristics for Phase two so all of
these individuals were between ages 50
to 70 including both females and males
and the melanomas at the bottom rows
there were stages either 1a or 2b
this result shows ROI clustering by cell
type and by tumor type and it shows how
nicely the ROI cluster so if we look at
the top bar it shows clustering by ROI
type so on the left the left-sided
cluster is the immune rich area in the
center is a mallanna side rich area on
the next to that is an area with the
keratinocytes and Malana site rich areas
and then on the right side we have
another immune rich area and then the
bars below show clustering within each
cell type by tumor type so if we look at
the immune rich area on the left side we
see that the melanomas cluster on the
left of that and then the neva on the
right of that and if we look at the
Milano side rich area Milan side ratar-o
eyes in the center we see the same thing
melanomas cluster on the left and then
Nev I on the right side so this this
clustering suggest that these each tumor
type they may have a distinct molecular
signature
so our next question was what is driving
the ROI clustering what genes are
driving it and we firstly wanted to
validate this using some of the
non-melanoma genesis associated genes
and then look at differential expression
analysis especially between nearby and
invasive melanoma and then comparing ROI
types separately so one of the non
melanoma Genesis genes that we looked at
equal to prime it stands for
preferentially expressed antigen in
melanoma and this gene is already used
in the available clinical diagnostic
assay there are two tests available one
is a adhesive patch RNA expression assay
that looks at the expression of two
genes one of which is prime and in this
test and basically is put on the lesion
on the skin and RNA is extracted from
that mainly RNA from the stratum corneum
or the top of the skin and and then
expression of the genes is looked at and
prime is one of them then there is
another essay that looks at expression
of roughly 23 genes of which prime is
one one off and this is used for
diagnosis of melanomas from FFPE
material
now these diagrams show expression of
frame in different roi types so we'll
focus on the melanocytes on the left
side and the diagram shows a comparison
between Niva and melanoma so on the
x-axis is full change relative to nev i
and on the y axis is significant
so in melanomas frame chose to full
change relative to nev i validating the
the assay further and then on the next
slide here we looked at the immune micro
environment and looked at antigen
presentation genes and expression
differences between melanomas and neva
and now we'll focus on the immune rich
ro is on the right side and again the
same thing where x axis is full change
in melanoma relative to nev i and y axis
is significant so there are numerous
immune rich numerous immune associated
genes that are elevated in terms of
expression in melanoma compared to
nearby
like to summarize the study so firstly
we learned that early diagnosis of
melanoma is critical to improved
survival the problem however is that a
subset of melanomas are difficult to
diagnose accurately therefore there's
growing interest in novel molecular
technologies however the current tests
that are available do not necessarily
work well for tumors that have low
cellularity and purity and these types
of tumors post challenges to these
current technologies
therefore we looked at spatially result
analysis that might enable
identification of novel biomarkers for
improved bergna improved diagnosis as
well as improved prognostic
stratification of patients and in this
study we showed the technical
reproducibility
of the assay as well as we showed some
data on the performance of the study in
terms of identify and identifying novel
biomarkers in Milan acidic tumors and
with that I would like to thank you for
your attention